science news der erste geklonte
unterwelt wurde dreifach wieder clown
hundebesitzer leben länger selbst
zweifler für kürzere feld haben
niedrigere löhne und optische
täuschungen verbessern die sega und
damit herzlich willkommen bei silence
news freunde der sonne setzt euch wir
haben keine zeit zu verlieren in der
welt der wissenschaft passieren so viele
dinge ich kann nicht über alles in extra
video machen deswegen habe ich heute 5
news aus der aktuellen forschung für
euch um 1 geklonte buggys vielleicht
erinnert sich ja jemand 2005 wurde der
erste geklonte hund der welt geboren
yapi leider verstarb snuppy im alter von
zehn jahren genauso wie sein vorgänger
teil an krebs aber kein grund zur
traurigkeit dem snuppy wurde wieder
geklont und zwar direkt drei mal wie das
funktioniert ganz einfach man nimmt eine
hunde in dem die dna heraus zu dafür
snuppy zellen rein die wir uns natürlich
im alter von fünf jahren entnommen und
setzt dann die embryonen kunde
leihmüttern ein neues nazis kamen
letztes jahr zur welt die ergebnisse
wurden diesen monat veröffentlicht ein
welpe starb leider nach der geburt die
anderen drei erfreuen sich derzeit
bester gesundheit und sie werden in den
nächsten zehn jahren hoffentlich viele
neue wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
liefern
übers kleidern und vielleicht sogar über
krebs apropos runde nummer zwei
hundebesitzer leben länger und erkranken
seltener an herz kreislauf erkrankungen
besonders zahlt sich ein hund für
alleinlebende aus da liegt das
sterberisiko etwa 33 prozent niedriger
als bei hunde losen und auch das
herzinfarktrisiko ist niedrig so viel
zur korrelation was die kausalen
zusammenhänge betrifft das gilt es jetzt
herauszufinden ist es die soziale
bindung oder das tägliche gassi gehen an
der frischen luft weitere forschung wird
es vielleicht zeigen nun mal drei
menschen die glauben sich weniger zu
bewegen sterben früher was glaubst du
legst du dich mehr oder weniger ist der
durchschnitt dass bewegungsmangel
ungesund ist das ist vielfach belegt
jetzt stellt sich heraus dass allein der
glaube daran sich zu wenig zu bewegen
bereits ungesund ist und das sogar
unabhängig davon wie man sich
tatsächlich bewegt einer untersuchung
von 60.000 amerikaner
zeigte sich dass diejenigen glaubten
sich weniger zu bewegen als der
durchschnitt ein höheres sterberisiko
haben ob eine negative
selbsteinschätzung auch tatsächlich die
ursache für ein kürzeres leben ist das
gilt es herauszufinden
jedenfalls erinnert das an andere
studien die herausfanden dass menschen
die sich selbst zu dick findet ihr ein
herz kreislauf erkrankungen leiden auch
wenn sie normalgewicht habe nummer vier
ältere väter haben niedrigere söhne
wissenschaftler haben sich selbst
untersucht nämlich nerds und nadine es
ist offenbar verehrt bar die forscher
quantifizierten die nadine es anhand
eines index das denk ich mir nicht aus
das steht genauso in peking qin decks
der sich an drei faktoren fest macht und
zwar erstens nonverbale intelligenz
zweiter starker fokus auf spezial
interessen und drittens ja ein
distanziertes soziales verhalten damit
fanden die forscher heraus dass die
index zu fast 60 prozent erblich
bedingtes und das digitimes oder nadine
es mit dem alter des vaters steigt und
nummer fünf ich zeige euch eine optische
täuschung mit der ihr eure sehkraft
verbessern könnte wenn auch nur
kurzzeitig optische täuschungen tricksen
unser gehirn aus wenn man zum beispiel
auf eine spirale start die sich im
uhrzeigersinn dreht und dann nach
irgendwas anderes anschaut dann sieht es
aus als würden die dinge wachsen größer
wären das testen wir auch gleich nur was
die forscher damit herausgefunden haben
dass ziemlich verblüfft
die forscher zeigten versuchsteilnehmern
genau das hier und danach konnten diese
kleine buchstaben bei einem sehtest
besser entziffern ist hier geht man
davon aus dass sie kraft ausschließlich
etwas mit dem zustand unserer augen zu
tun hat also dem physiologischen zustand
diese studie zeigt erstmals dass das
ganze auch etwas mit unserer art
wahrnehmung zu tun haben könnte wie das
ganze aussieht seid ihr bereit diese
testen schau dir jetzt auf dem
bildschirm
und jetzt und wer dich immer größer
rheine der sonne das war eine auswahl
aus aktueller forschung alle paper hab
ich euch natürlich unten verlinkt in
gerade dabei ein paar neue formate
auszutesten einfach das heißt wenn euch
das ja gefallen hat dann lasst es mich
irgendwie wissen macht sich irgendwie
bemerkbar wenn es gut ankommt dann mache
ich das gerne auch nochmal ansonsten you
know the jewel wir sehen uns nächste
woche plötzlich leute hören doch keine
zeit wir sind hier bei science news